man I have a secret City this heavy
since we switched the sauce hopefully I
can be a good face of the league for
everyone
what's going on
Zion
he's got a new body
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
why is everyone so excited about this
ion he hasn't really done anything
Dylan get the greatest into safety
according to the overly detailed diagram
in my head nothing can stop Zion once he
gets through the perimeter
don't worry there's strength in numbers
[Music]
I still remember your weakness
oh even his kicks have changed time to
get flashy
Association is controlling him
Zion let's promise I'll always be best
friends promise now let's go destroy
some fellow children
the code
spoiler alert I was in there the whole
time
oh
thanks bro they really tried to pit us
against each other those old Heads Stay
controlling the narrative we gotta fight
back follow me
once John Zion take each other out
nothing will be in our way
yeah nothing
are we sure we want to activate
him the association of Hollywood to
attack them where it hurts
the rising young stars are finally
fighting the old heads they're even
taking down some legends from within
their own ranks there's no doubt a new
class of Heroes has risen up
there ain't no way LeBron and those bus
rides take it out their kids takes about
the dinner maybe look at you already
talking about food I know you're not
talking are you talking about this
barbecue chicken at least I got rings
foreign
[Music]